great everyone I'm a lot of non
millennial and today we're talking about
everything to lynnea's keep motoring
nothing is not bouncing Millennials who
is so lazy and entitled that they want
to spend all that money on avocados and
coffee and it still wasn't complain
about not being ever bought a house did
you buy too many avocado it is not
because of running out of land and
exclusionary regions where there is
going to diminish the supply of new
housing and it is definitely not because
older investors buying into the rental
market which currently holds the largest
share of income of the United States so
today we're counting down my top 10
things Millennials ruined 2005 i'm
millennial retail accounting it's fine
did you not millennials killed the suit
apparently this is related a company
hiring members of a team who are
incapable of differentiating between
what and what isn't appropriate in terms
of clothing apparently 75 cent ironman
adjusting to milano failed to west
appropriate interview attire Malayala
also killed the gulf industry
millennials has killed gulf by not being
into gulf which is terrible news for the
industry as a whole can you get it whole
scope you wouldn't understand you're not
a millennial finally got statistics
maybe young people are not interested in
golf in boomers are aging out being the
entire industry is in decline
look millennials are all trashed by a
garbage but have you considered the
problem is your marketing strategy if
you're worried that only old people play
golf and young people don't want to try
and marketing to young people
Millennials are also killing lunch you
know that popular time to eat food
millennial about having any of it
this next one's a big one you get ready
millennials also killed the movie
business apparently the number of ticket
buyers aged 12 to 17 in 2015 fell down
to 5.3 million from 5.5 million in the
two previous years that said I think
Millennials should up their gave me I'm
not doing a great job during the movie
industry because number 10 and 11
highest-grossing films of all time came
out this year those of you in these and
say is curious but the third highest
grossing movie of all time is actually
the force awakens which obviously just
came out a couple of years ago now so I
don't think Molly I'm doing a great job
of killing the movie industry
yes we've got a little bit of work to do
on that one ah Millennials carrying the
vacation partly millenniums the worst
offenders when it comes to taking time
off and you know what I'm gonna
completely agree with this one but I
would argue that there is a reason that
Millennials are obsessed with work I
knew this predicted that the number one
reason that millennial don't take time
off work is because they're trying to
save money
oh man millennial have not yet killed
NFL but they cooked many mothers and
fathers of Millennials are not allowing
their kids to play tackle football
because of the health risks see the part
where you said mothers and fathers makes
it seem like it's their fault more so
than the Millennials fault but I don't
know what I'm talking about - whales are
also killing relationships and we should
probably be concerned about it
apparently the hookup culture has been
on the rise to the past several years as
a lot of Millennials are getting into
adulthood and starting to date times
boyfriend and girlfriend have become
almost as uncommon as Beyonce and smell
here's a good question why Millennials
killing their bosses now while myself
like a mother to work and many questions
a Google Wallet movement towards more
self management less organizational
hierarchy have some companies dropping
titles from their vocabulary
this sounds like efficiency sounds
efficient the Canadian tourism industry
where will it end contrary to the thing
that was said before about vacations
apparently this generation is eight
times more likely to take a lengthy
vacation outside of the country than
inside it Millennials have also killed
the McDonald's mcwrap their apps are
introduced in 2013 at a time when
McDonald's is struggling and hoping the
lowing other patrons who wanted to help
your life but the plan didn't do much
for the chain a lot of people who eat at
restaurants aren't interested in health
and wellness go give the people what
they want this this seems a little like
an overarching food problem rather than
a millennial specific hate for the
mcwrap but you know you do you imma let
you finish was that ten I know I can't
count I typically I do use my calculus
pretty much everything so
I may be killing math okay get old jokes
aside the Millennials are entitled and
complain too much stuff just seems
really ignorant to me the median price
of buying a house in the u.s. right now
is $300,000 recently less than 20% of
housing construction has been
entry-level which is considered housing
that you could buy at a young age and
this is considered to be the first time
in history of housing supply that one
entire generation is not being catered
to less houses being built means the
median price of houses goes up so
because that houses are about 80 to 100
percent higher than they were in the
2000s but unfortunately millenials
reading income has an increased to meet
rising housing costs mes 2000 the
average 25 to 35 year olds making around
$35,000 a year and that has declined in
2014 which is the most recent step that
I could find and adjusted for inflation
the Millennial to income averages around
$31,000 in other words less houses more
expensive houses lower income valid
complaints I think